[Music]
who am I you sure you want to
know if somebody told you I was just
your average ordinary guy not a care in
the
world somebody
[Music]
lied truth is it wasn't always like this
there was a time when life was a lot
less complicated can I take your picture
for the school paper sure and this lab
we have 15 Genetically Enhanced super
spiders there's 14 one's
missing Peter are you all
right I'm fine Pete look you're
changing I know I went through exactly
the same thing at your
age no it's not
[Music]
exactly
wow Peter may I introduce my father
Norman osbor great honor to meet you sir
Harry tells me you're quite the science
whz you know I'm something of a
scientist
myself what the hell was
that whatever it is somebody has to stop
it with great power comes great
responsibility this is my gift wow it is
my curse who are you who am
I I'm
Spider-Man do I get to say thank you
this
[Music]
time
you do too much you're not Superman you
know I believe there's a hero in all of
us gives us strength makes us know
even though sometimes we have to give up
the thing we want the most par what you
been looking for you all morning you're
late always late you're fired look at
you pet your grades have been declining
you always appear
exhausted I know I'm trying so where you
been pal you don't return my calls I've
been kind of busy taking pictures of
your friend Spider-Man killed my
father no matter what I do do you love
me or not
no matter how hard I try I want
Spider-Man dead it's the ones I love who
will always be the ones who pay I can't
keep thinking about you I'm getting
married I want a life of my
own I'm
Spider-Man no
more you look different I let things get
in the way before there was something I
thought I had to do I don't have to I
like seeing you tonight Peter now on to
the main event Octavius is going to put
Corp on the map in a way my father never
even dreamed
of crazy scientist turns himself into
some kind of a monster four mechanical
arms welded right onto his body you take
Spider-man's pictures where is he sickly
off your loyalty to Spider-Man and not
your best
friend bring Spider-Man to me how do I
find him Peter Parker find Spiderman or
I'll peel the Flesh of her
bones there there are bigger things
happening here than me and
you
[Music]
let's see who's behind the
mask
I'm going to ask MJ to marry me a man
has to put his wife before himself can
you do that Peter yeah I think I
can we have some new information this is
your uncle's actual killer we lost his
Trail two days
ago this man killed my uncle and he's
still out
there everybody needs help sometimes
Peter even
Spider-Man revenge it's like a poison
that can take us over and before you
know it I can turn you into something
ugly the suit where' this come from the
power it feels
good You Lose Yourself to
it whoa Spidey love the new outfit
remember Ben Parker what does it matter
to you anyway
everything do you want to push me away
why would I want to push you away I love
you you knew this was coming Pete I
didn't kill your
father what's happened to
[Music]
you we've all done terrible things to
each other we have to forgive each other
or everything we ever were will mean
nothing I need your help but I have to
stop
[Music]
it this could be the end of
[Applause]
Spider-Man
this life is not an easy
one I've made
enemies powerful
enemies put those I love in
danger but the one thing that has
haunted
me my entire
life is finding the truth about my
[Music]
terance you're a wanted man Peter
Parker don't believe what the police are
saying to
you my dad has 500 officers looking for
you 500 that seems a bit
excessive you know if you're going to
steal cars don't dress like a carp you
found my weakness it's small
knives who are
[Music]
you tell us a little bit about yourself
Mr
Parker what did your father do Peter I
never really knew my father my parents
left when I was very young Peter someday
we all understand
it did you tell the boy about his
father not Conor I'm Richard Parker's
son if you want the truth about your
parents Peter come and get
it ready to play
God there's been a biological attack on
New York
City P Secrets have a
cost I got to stop
him do you think what happened to you
Peter was an
accident do you have any
idea
but you really
[Music]
are
Peter
every day I wake up knowing that the
more people I try to
say the more enemies I will
make and it's just a matter of time
before I face those with more
power than I can
overcome I'm so sorry I'm
late I had a traffic thing did your
traffic jam have anything to do with
being I don't know shot at by machine
guns yeah yeah that was implied that was
implying
that Peter Parker Mar osbor you're going
to want to see this oor get you under
surveillance why isn't that the question
of the
day there's something you're not telling
me yet may I once told you that Secrets
have a
cost the truth does too
my name is Richard Parker I have
discovered what OS Corp was going to use
my research for I have a responsibility
to protect the world from what I know
they're capable
of what is all this the
future we literally can change the
world what about Peter not everyone has
a happy
ending
this is bigger than you
Peter I made a choice this is my
path soon everyone in the city will know
how it feels to live in a
world without
power without
[Music]
Mercy without
Spiderman
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers I can tell Hulk gives
it
away
oh that was
[Music]
awesome is Liz a new top no we've seen
that before never with that skirt should
probably stop staring before it gets
creepy though yeah too
late guys are
losers so to become an Avenger are there
like trials or andw just don't do
anything I would do and definitely don't
do anything I wouldn't do there's a
little gray area in there and that's
where you operate oh all right that's
not a hug I'm just grabbing the door for
you all right kid good luck out
there listen I know School socks Peter
you still with us uh yeah yeah I know
you want to save the world
but you're not ready
yet you're the Spider-Man no I'm not I'm
not this is just a costume this she from
the
ceiling stay close to the
ground and stay out of
trouble forget the flying monster guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing oh SI could been treating me like
a kid all the time but you are a kid
this is my chance to prove
myself what is going on with you I'm
really sorry I'm so busy I'm
slammed don't mess with me cuz I will
kill you and everybody you
love miles yeah got to go if you want me
to drive you we got to go now personal
chauffeur going on it's okay seriously
dad walking would have been fine
breaking news Spider-Man saves the day
again Spider-Man this guy swings once a
day Zip Zap z n
accountability man you get arrested guys
don't cops Run Red Lights well yeah some
do but uh not your dad in your Universe
there's only one
Spider-Man but there is another Universe
it looks and sounds like yours but it's
[Music]
not my name is Miles
Morales Hey
kid you're like me
how I know it's
complicated you want to know what
happened to you I can teach you to be
Spider-Man I love this burger so
delicious it's one of the best burgers
I've ever had you have money right I'm
not very liquid right now I think you're
going to be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think of about
saving the world you have to think about
saving one
person one thing I know for sure don't
do it like
me do it like
[Applause]
[Music]
you I see this spark in you it's amazing
hands up whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be
great I love you miles yeah I know
dad you got to say I love you back Dad
are you serious I want to hear it you
want to hear me say I love you Dad
you're dropping me off out of school
love you Dad look at this place dad I
love you dad I love you that's a
copy time to swing just like I taught
you when did you teach me that I didn't
it's a little joke the team
building hey guys okay who are you I'm
Gwen Stacy come on how many more spider
people are there save it for Comic Con
what's comic let's
go everywhere I go I see his
face just really miss him yeah I miss
him
too I don't think Tony would have done
what he did if he didn't know that you
were going to be here after he was
gone you going to be the next Iron Man
now well no I don't have time I'm too
busy doing your jobs what kidding I'm
kidding look keep up the good work
because I am going on
vacation heads up Nick Fury's calling
you I don't really want to talk to Nick
Fury why because if you don't talk to
him then I have to talk to I don't want
to talk to them you sent Nick Fury to
voicemail I got to go you do not ghost
Nick Fury what up dorks what's up we're
just talking about the trip I'm here in
St Marco Polo I think MJ really likes me
my first one
Al you very difficult person to contact
Spider-Man this is Mr Beck you could
have used Someone Like You on my world
your world Beck is from Earth just not
ours a snap T to our hole in our
Dimension you're saying there's a
Multiverse we have a job to do you're
coming with
us there's got to be somethingone else
you can use where about Thor off world
Captain Marvel
unavailable
I'm just a friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man please you've been to
space what do you want
Peter I want to go back on my trip with
the girl who I really like and tell her
how I feel MJ I am Spider-Man no of
course I'm not I mean it's kind of
obvious you're right you may not be
ready but this is my responsibility
saving the world requires
sacrifice sometimes people
die
oh my God just always feel like I'm
putting my friends in danger the world
needs next Iron
Man you going to step up or
[Music]
not I got to get you guys out of here
get on the jet who are you I work with
Spider-Man you work for Spider-Man I
work with Spider-Man not for Spider-Man
new
plan oh look at this this is a good one
some suggest that Parker's powers
include the male spider's ability to
hypnotize females stop come on yes my
spider
Lord can we just like stay up here all
day it is so crazy down
there that's right folks Spider-Man is
in fact Peter Parker listen I did not
kill Mysterio the drones did the drones
that are
yours does does any part of you feel
relieved about all this what do you
mean now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record I never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
Spider-Man now everybody knows but this
isn't about me this is hurting a lot of
people I've just been thinking about how
to fix all of
this so Peter what do I hold the
pleasure I'm sorry to bother you sir
please we saved half the universe
together I think we're Beyond you
calling me sir okay
Steven that feels weird but I'll allow
it when Mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up I was
wondering if maybe you could make it so
that he never
did strange don't cast that spell it's
too dangerous fine I
won't
the entire world is about to forget the
Peter Parker is Spider-Man wait
everyone can't some people still know
that's not how the spell works so MJ's
going to forget about everything we've
ever been through stop tampering with
the spell oh my God Ned he's my best
friend my a May should really know stop
talking what just
happened we tempered with the stability
of
SpaceTime Multiverse is a concept about
which we know frighteningly
little the problem is you trying to live
two different
lives the longer you do it the more
dangerous it
becomes be careful what you wish for
Parker
hello
[Music]
Peter my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man and
things are going great oh yeah you were
supposed to be here fine all right
whatever whatever wow whatever so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian I am the
spot that's not funny don't don't do
that miles's grades are pretty good A in
AP Physics that's my little man and a B
in Spanish what okay miles are you
trying I got to go all right bye he's
lying to you and I think you know
[Music]
iter miles want to get out of here oh
when so wait a minute there's an elite
crew with all the best spider people in
it who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the
lobby Miguel O'Hara the whole thing was
his idea what's the guy got to do to
join this spider team you can never be
part of this don't even get me started
on Doctor Strange and the Little Nerd
back on Earth
199999 come on go easy on the kid he had
a terrible teacher Peter oh
you have a baby I have a
baby I'll take it from
here miles being Spider-Man is a
sacrifice you have a choice between
saving one
person and sa in every
World send me home I can't do that I can
do both Spiderman always not always what
about Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben
most of us would wouldn't be
here can't stop me now you can't run
forever kid I can't lose one more friend
D this isn't what we talked about you
knew you had no idea what you're doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to
go nah I'm going to do my own
[Music]
thing all station stop
Spider-Man
you
[Music]
and then I looked at my uncle and uh let
me guess he
[Music]
died